ich weiß nicht was die wissenschaftler
zb posten tatsächlich dann der politik
raten aber wenn ich
daran denke noch mal einen kleinen
schritt zurück die zahl er war ja immer
da 1 und darunter das haben wir nun
schon seit monaten und das interessiert
heute keinen menschen mehr
ja damals war das also das ganz große
ziel dann hatten wir vor weihnachten den
anstieg über von von 8000 auf 10 auf 20
auf 30.000 jetzt auf einmal sind wir bei
9000 ist aber auch nicht recht weil
wahrscheinliche gesundheitsämter nicht
richtig arbeiten dann frage ich mich in
den gesundheits und dann sitzen überall
beamte und angestellte des öffentlichen
dienstes die so schafft man das nicht
dass die nun endlich mal die zahlen
liefern und sie auch bewerten
es ist also gerade noch mal einen haken
das hat gestern ein oppositionspolitiker
mir gesagt er verstehe überhaupt nicht
warum nicht seit frühjahr zum beispiel
längst mehr in digitalisierung
investiert wurde bei den
gesundheitsämtern aber auch was die app
angeht und am ende sagt er zeigt es sich
eben auch beim impfstoff das sozusagen
in der planung in der koordination im
management muss man so sagen nicht
richtig vorgegangen wurde
ja die auffassung kann man urteilen und
und das als missmanagement eigentlich
als totales versagen auf dieser
kommunalen ebene daneben auch bezeichnen
denn ich kann als bürgermeister oder als
zuständiger natürlich die meine
mitarbeiter im gesundheitsamt
verpflichten dann sondern am sonntag
dienst zu tun und das zu machen
ich kann nur sagen aus der eigenen
erfahrung ich habe das als tschernobyl
damals hoch ging haben wir wochenlang
die becquerel gemessen auf den jahren
blicken und das zwar sondern und sonntag
auch also da ist gar nichts besonderes
dort und das kann man ja wohl erwarten
nach neun monaten das dann immer noch
kommt ja die zahl von heute ist nicht so
genau wissen noch nicht wie sie ist da
kommt noch etwas hinterher gekleckert
entschuldigung wir machen ihr
entscheidungen für das ganze volk die
wirtschaft hat probleme die einzelnen
menschen haben probleme
und dann ist es nicht möglich
vernünftige zahlen vom montag
von sonntag auf montag zu liefern
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren